here
drum roll
all right we got lee roy
uh you can't go wrong with me
i feel like you just can't go wrong for
sure
yeah i would say his weakness is his
range actually he doesn't have a lot of
good like mid-range tools like it's like
down one plus two four four two two is a
good gap closer i guess
uh still a little bit punishable though
like his back will plus two twelve frame
mid counter and launcher is fantastic
frame data wise but uh it is very short
right it's very short on a range and it
has a lot of recovery frames that they
added i think they added ten recovery
frames to it when they changed it into
the patch wherever i go
oh this ain't just going in
yeah and leeroy downpour one is actually
one of the best things about him like
the range on that move is crazy like if
there's a fan trying to backstream blow
that down one's gonna find him uh which
is just ridiculous and also very low the
ground to pick up the combos too
red man here with the launch redman
to take the first round and just
lose this round one
fight yeah yeah and steve had so little
health there like he was scared of a low
poke right so you probably tried a fuzzy
low prairie or low block and the rage i
just clipped them
uh so bread man with that first round
nice perry second hit there yeah perry
is definitely leroy's best tool right
yeah it makes them so scary just they're
back oh here we go
three jabs until down for two years
all right you can do it again
bread mad looking to do something rage
oh there's a stick we're talking about
visual range he does have the stick yeah
but saint is a nun
i know that that's hard to duck and
punish but to throw out a hide in that
situation
cojones
there we go down for three
times oh he gets it
oh he gets up with the downpour you got
bro
this that round was so fast
he's such a jack player right that's
basically down back one four times
yeah yeah
yeah oh man he's got him
yeah yes
red man
at the wall now
oh
saint doing whatever he wants
oh hold his foot over here bro
i do what i want everything's gonna hit
rent free dude
crazy yeah that was right definitely
like for a game one situation to have
that many correct reads it's pretty
bonkers uh you know say definitely
playing fantastic right now but bread
man uh definitely lost and confused at
the moment like how the hell is
everything wrong you know it's like he
might as well be in vegas you know
gambling on slots and losing every
single time because that's literally
what's happening right now uh cindy's
just on point every decision is the
correct one it's crazy
yeah yeah those
threes that's the
there's like a there's definitely like
that mental game you're talking about
the the downpour threes and the you know
and the the mids uh mixing it up and uh
and definitely i felt like he he kind of
he kind of like clammed up a little bit
and like it's just like oh nothing's
working so i'm just gonna block and he
just kind of got himself to the wall and
and i just pressured him to death there
so
um so yeah he's gonna have to shake it
off maybe maybe this will be what uh
prompts him to make the switch switch to
lydia
getting into i mean
i feel like i would if i'm leroy and i'm
dealing with someone who i know it's
good he's gonna mix with one of the two
options i'm just spamming perry for
every option like yeah just i'm going to
parry if the loyalty loads and hit me
anyway if he does the middle
yeah
um
yeah maybe that's what he needs to see
though to go to the green howard says
howard estate now
um yeah stain just being a bully so far
[Music]
round one all right
fight power to stay we saw brad man on
the stage before did pretty well with it
uh you know that sweep from leroy does
break the wall as well so the sweet
becomes a combo starter at that
situation
probably what he's thinking about
duck no duck
oh again oh okay nice sidewalk here nice
combo though oh
finishing the strings yeah finishes the
string yeah
fine
and you know there's no pairings coming
out from bread man here right very very
minimal i should say yeah and one of the
options leroy has he has a ford one
which is like an attack that has a very
built in so it's like if you're scared
to just whip a parry there's the parries
at least
behind it
there's a duck this time
yeah
hey scared of the third hit there
yeah try and try over maybe get get one
of those threes oh
take your stick out of here no canes
allowed big name boom to the wall and
the wall then he's gonna be able to kill
here this
dude
this is beat down
hey chad you guys are all still talking
about how leroy's broken right
at that
that was so perfect from saying the
spacing on that
and garner looking so strong right now
okay here we go here come the sleeve
clap them all
clap
crumples oh switching side though
yeah stan is still a little bit too
copper right now
yeah
he is slowing it down a little bit
right now
oh
man
wow three rounds straight out of here
leroy
out of here out of the tournament see
you later thanks for playing uh damn
nice try for bread man but really think
was all over all the right decisions
there
and you know he was trying he was doing
the leroy things but they just not